there's a scene in kickboxer that's one  of my favorite scenes and I think you're  going to know what I'm talking about  where you're the the guy who's training  you wants you to dance yeah it's a it's  a terrific scene what's what so this is  going back quite a ways now but it's a  it still holds up let's take a look at  this scene from kickboxer  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  by the way we're gonna do a kickboxing -  you got your - yeah first in line yeah  well with batiste  GSP alum you see all good actors are  gonna be a cool movie do you still have  are you still can you still dance like  that you still got those dance moves  let's go get the move if we gave you  some music right now could you do it  [Applause]  you have to put loud  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]